we're given that angle adb is congruent
to angle adc so let me write that down
so angle a d b so that's this angle
right over here they're telling us that
that's congruent to a d c a dc so that's
this angle right over there they also
tell us that angle bad angle bad angle
bad angle b a d so that's this angle
i'll do it with two arcs because it's
not necessarily the same measure as this
one here so angle bad is congruent to
angle cad that's angle cad so this is
this angle right over here
prove that triangle bad triangle bad
this is a triangle on the left is
congruent to triangle c80 that's this
triangle on the right and so they they
give the givens here angle bad is
congruent to cad bad is congruent to cad
well they've already told us that and
they also told us that angle adb is
congruent to adc
adb is congruent to adc so we've already
marked that up so how do we prove this
well the one thing we know and this is
almost intuitively obvious is that the
measure of this segment is equal to
itself and the reason why that's a
useful thing to state explicitly is
because that side the segment a d is
part of both triangles so let's just
mark that there it's equal to itself so
let me write this here
and the reason why it's useful is you're
kind of saying hey look this is a side
on both of those triangles that we care
about so we could write a d
is congruent to a d and it'd be by the
reflexive property which is the most
obvious property that something is going
to be equal to itself so reflexive pop
property there you go
but now by stating that we've explicitly
put up enough information in our proof
to now say that the left the left
triangle is congruent to the right and
the reason why we can say that is we
have a corresponding angle corresponding
side and then another corresponding
angle that is congruent to this angle
this side and this angle and we talk
about in other videos about why angle
side angle works if i have one triangle
that has congruent one angle a side and
another angle that's congruent to
another triangle it's impossible for me
to draw a triangle that is not congruent
this is a basic axiom that we assume
it's a basic assumption so now we have
enough information we can now write that
triangle bad
triangle ba d and we want to make sure
we have the corresponding sides so what
corresponds to to angle b or vertex b
right over here is
c
so it's going to be c and then we'd want
to go to a and then d c a d and the
reason is we have an angle a side and an
angle so let me get it angle side angle
congruence
there you go and i think we are done
let's see how we did
there you go